Prime Minister kiriakos matsutakes has
wasted no time over the summer he
delivered on a promise to cut property
tax and this month plans to rollback
corporate and income taxes that rose
sharply during the country's economic
crisis and the government is fast
tracking flagship investments in gold
mining Port development and urban
redevelopment that the previous cities
our government had frozen been enormous
lethargy lethargy
life hasn't become better for the Greeks
in two months but stone by stone the
foundations for the country's rebirth
are being laid for the first time after
ten years of crisis there's a glimmer of
hope that the brighter Greece was spoken
of is not an impossible dream in the
market the expected tax cuts don't yet
translate to higher sales say business
owners Mariano volatile Pulu and her
family have fought to keep alive a 50
year old business in threads and yarns
and last year was their worst of the
crisis she says but things changed after
the July general election the psychology
has changed a lot
changing government always helps but I
think it's more than that I see a
certain optimism better climate a sense
of expectation the same is true for
basic needs
there's no uptick yet but people here
are more hopeful through this fruit
stand
Eleni category and her brother support
their families as well as their mother
who can't survive on a pension we
haven't seen a change in the market yet
I hope Mitsotakis passes the tax cuts
the previous government was a disaster
thank goodness they've gone our hopes
are pinned on this government outside
the hall where me to thank you spoke
labor unions marked their presence as
they always do at the country's biggest
annual trade fair not to oppose
government policy but to press even
harder for an end to austerity
Mitsotakis is giving people hope that
after a decade of recession and high
taxes he will deliver on his promise of
growth for all business and consumer
sentiment are at a 12-year high and
global markets have given him a vote of
confidence
Greece's cost of borrowing has fallen by
two percentage points since the election
was announced and Mitsotakis is showing
he means business his first act of
Parliament created the most powerful
Secretariat a Greek Prime Minister has
ever had to monitor his cabinets
performance jumps our applause al
Jazeera Thessaloniki